this is an overview of the new geometry
features in version 11 version 11 adds
numerous extensions and improvements to
the already strong capabilities in
geometric computing it is now possible
to construct regions from arrays and
images or to immediately access them
from curated collections a full
integration into the Wolfram language
makes it easy to analyze solve over
visualize and 3d print regions let's
start by looking at the new special
regions regular polygon annulus stadium
shape and seven more basic regions have
been added to the already extensive list
of 2d regions seven new 3d regions have
been added including spherical shell and
capsule shell hyperplane half space
affine space a fine half space are among
the new in dimensional regions in
version 11 bounding regions for points
and meshes can be computed in any
dimension for display spatial query or
spatial indexing purposes let's find the
minimum volume ball that encapsulates
the mesh you can also showcase the mesh
with in various bounding regions with
the following function new mesh regions
can easily be created from arrays with
the new function array mesh here's an
example of how to generate color to
trauma notes version 11 introduces the
image mesh function to for conversion
from 2d and 3d images two meshes start
with an image of the Great Salt Lake and
a segmentation via the region growing
create a 2d mesh of the image similarly
take a 3d image of an engine and create
a 3d mesh of the image version 11
supports the import and export of 3d
geometry from all standard formats
including Dae performance improvements
are available across the board compare
the timings for import of the STL file
format the number at the bottom tells
how many times faster Mathematica 11 is
compared to Mathematica 10 a large
volume of curated mesh regents specially
organized and created for the Wolfram
language is now available and easily
accessible using the property region
version 11 introduces roll pitch yaw
matrix to describe a sequence of
rotations with respect to a fixed
coordinate frame it is often used to
model rigid body rotations in robotics
and aerospace the new Oyler matrix
function describes a sequence of
rotations with respect to a moving
coordinate frame let's model a gimbal
each Euler angle is the relative angle
of turn for each axis you can explore
new capabilities covering physical
parameters of a rigid body including
rotational inertia pick a point for the
wrench to rotate about the inertia
matrix is centered at this point the
support of polynomial moments of a
region of version 11 provides powerful
and flexible tools to compare classify
and compute properties over regions here
we symbolically calculate moments of
regions Wolfram language functions for
visualizing functions and data now
support arbitrary regions for the most
control over domains and slices plot the
function sine X plus cosine Y over the
disk centered at the region with radius
3 version 11 adds extensive support for
symbolic and numerical solutions of
boundary value problems or regions solve
the derrick lay problem for the applause
equation in a disk here we compute the
acoustic ogen values and eigen functions
for an approximation of a cross-section
through many import an image of the
cross section use the mask tool to
create a boundary graphic discretize the
graphic
compute 6i ghen values and eigen
functions of the cross section visualize
the second eigen function in the cross
section of the car a whole set of themes
are now available in version 11 too
easily and automatically change how mesh
regions look for a variety of situations
and uses these include the common based
themes as well as font size mesh and
rendering feature themes shown in this
table version 11 significantly extends
the geometry capabilities with new
region constructors along with new and
improved solvers over regions it also
introduces useful mesh functions for 3d
printing view the geometry guide page
and marketing page to find out more
about the new features